sorry to bother you I'm a big fan of
Hatter's your resistance right yeah I
just I had to come up and say hello
[Music]
Heather has a love like nothing to tell
you Stan do alcohol here please why are
we here you've a gun right feel like
there's so many crazy people who are mad
at me right now you know how to shoot a
gun how many movies have I shotguns in -
you know how your thank you don't feel
safe I feel like that all
[Music]
I felt like you're feeling right now
usually I'm so tough for me to ask you
about ask you are you definitely you
remember things am i right I think you
might remember things more than most
people think back what is the last thing
you saw in this house
did she ever threaten you
no she's incredibly could I've heard
stories about movie stars my under
arrest
oh yeah
motive opportunity capacity until we're
like freaking best friend and collect
that kill each other all the time are
you fell in I'm asking a careful you
might not think something's important in
them
bingo secure the whole thing
you